Actor, director and former football player
Carl Weathers has passed away.
Weathers is best known for his role
in Rocky Predator and Happy Gilm
Your kids
probably know him as the voice of
Carl in Toy Story or as Greef Ca
in the Star Wars series The Mand
Weathers manager says he died
peacefully in his home.
He had recently turned 76 years
Carl Weathers debuted on the sil
in 1975 in the blaxploitation
film Bucktown.
What is keeping him up? I don't
But he became a star playing the
boxing champ,
Apollo Creed, in the 1976 hit Ro
What started out as a low budget
sleeper won three Academy Awards
including Best Picture.
The whole world was going to see
the real Apollo Creed Lightning
and hard to catch, no plane,
no drive, and just business.
Weathers appeared in three Rocky
sequels, playing Rocky's nemesis
manager and friend.
The former linebacker with the O
Raiders
earned a degree in drama
from San Francisco State Univers
He said he was inspired
to become an actor.
Watching Sidney Poitier in the 1
The Defiant Ones.
Years
later, Weathers starred in its T
Along the way,
he embodied the 80 strong man
sharing the big screen
with Charles Bronson and Dave Hu
Make it easy on yourself.
And later, Arnold Schwarzenegger
in Predator Look schedule.
Gale Weathers also took charge
on the small screen on
shows like Fortune, Dane and Tou
But one role Weathers Felt
gave him a chance to go deeper a
was chief of police
in the heat of the night.
The part allowed him to grapple
with tough social issues.
Now you're threatening
to commit a serious crime. Mr.
Buford Weathers appeared in the
show's last two seasons and said
the more cerebral role was a hap
from years of backbreaking stunt
An alligator bit my hand. Oh, my
Weathers found comic relief in h
as Adam Sandler's alligator hati
golf instructor Chubbs Peterson
Gilmore in Arrested Development.
He played a penny pinching actin
All I know is no chewing coach.
Do you want to chew it or not?
In 2019, Weathers found a new yo
audience in the popular Star War
The Mandalorian, playing the lea
of an intergalactic bounty Hunte
He received an Emmy nomination
for that role
and directed many episodes of th
It's always such a joy
to provide entertainment
for people who really enjoy what
Carl Weathers, an action star
who lit up screens with heft and